first person shooters are awesome
they're action-packed games backed by
incredible graphics
and if i wanted to quickly make an fps
there's some really great options
you've got easy tutorials in unreal
engine and unity even comes with a fully
featured fps sample that works right out
of the box but what if you wanted to
build one using something else weirdly
enough anything javascript related isn't
really that high or even present on the
list of engines that you might use
i feel like i can make it work though
first person camera systems are
conceptually pretty simple
you've just got the camera wedged in the
guys or the girl's chest and every
movement happens relative to your
orientation
i started by working on getting simple
camera movement working first
it doesn't take much to get a simple
scene with simple camera movement going
the devil's in the details though can
play around quite a bit with getting
little details in like that head bobbing
effect it's just a sine wave that you
apply to the camera as you move although
one little detail of that is that you
ideally want to stop at the end of a
step otherwise you stop higher or lower
like we've done here so a little bit of
extra code to dig into these kind of
details really helps
once that's working you may notice the
problem
the problem is that we can just pass
through walls we have no collision
detection whatsoever so we'll be
integrating some sort of physics engine
i've been using ammo.js in projects
which is actually the bullet physics
engine a great little open source
physics engine that's good enough for
red dead redemption so it should be more
than good enough for us too this should
have been easy but in reality it wasn't
the docs suck the examples suck
everything sucks including me i kind of
suck at physics
anyway with enough trawling through
forums and stack overflow i was able to
cobble together a working bt kinematic
character controller snippet of code and
the end result that i can run around i
can't pass through walls anymore but i
can slide along them at angles though i
can do all the things that you'd expect
including jump look i can jump that came
along as a nice little bonus
let's add some guns now
i grabbed this gun off of sketch fab it
looked pretty cool so i'm happy there's
not much to making it look first person
shootery just gotta offset it right
until it's roughly where we want it
relative to the camera
after that shooting is up next and the
trick here is to use ammo.js's
raycasting abilities to cast a ray out
from our gun barrel and see what it hits
so whenever i press the mouse button we
fire off a raycast query
and figure out if we hit anything and
then react appropriately depending on
what you hit
i'm not a violent guy though so we'll
make this a paintball gun instead of a
killing people gun
so to get that splat effect we could use
textures but i'm going to hijack 3.js's
shaders to do this procedurally for more
variation
we also use 3.js's deco system to
procedurally create decals from the
underlying geometry
now when i fire off a shot look at that
we do a little splat on the wall and we
get our paintball effect
the cool thing about this is that it
rounds corners nicely and you get
different pattern each time you fire a
shot
easing functions are an awesome little
tool to have in your toolbox as a
programmer
because you can use them to procedurally
add animations to shaders or meshes like
magic i added an exponential impulse to
blend between two rotation quaternions
and the end result is a little firing
recoil when you take a shot
you can of course play with it maybe
recoil more like a machine gun instead
of a pistol up to you
the next step is that i wanted to add
some ui
i took doom eternal as my inspiration
and figured i could pretty much copy
their layout
the nice thing about using javascript is
that i can do this all in html and css
if you want to call that a nice thing
so i threw some styled elements onto the
screen with 3d transforms and box
shadows and sourced a bunch of icons
from google's free library
so we have our health and charge bars
down here i give this guy a charge up
power to run super fast takes down the
bar by just adjusting the width and
changing the color
on the right here's some more ui i kind
of drew this in [ __ ] but the rest of it
is icons and text
at the top i'm actually not quite sure
what this does in doom so i put some
random icons up here
i worked on adding enemies next
i grabbed this little robot thing from
quaternious
comes fully animated already i just
plopped him into the world but he
doesn't do anything right now
we can fix that by adding some crude ai
if we give him his own collision
detection like we have for ourselves and
then throw together a quick finite state
machine that has him in idle walk and
shooting behaviors
we can really quickly and easily give
him a bit of personality
see now he sees me and walks towards me
and even tries to impotently shoot at me
too bad only i have the gun
so yeah of course next thing is you give
him a gun
and i also coded up this forcefield
thing using some voronoi noise
now he's trying to take shots at me and
he has this cool little force field
around him
and if i take a step back here and fire
off a few shots at him his shield kind
of changes color and eventually he dies
and i added this quick dissolve away
effect
pretty happy how easy that was
let's make this look better now
let's make a quick level so what i'll do
here is i'll quickly place down some
cubes and planes and stuff kind of
randomly
we'll also place a few models that i
grabbed off of sketchfab that looked
pretty cool
that looks kind of neat we've got
floating islands at different levels now
and i can run around to jump and play
and do whatever i want
from the corners though you can see that
this doesn't look as good as it could
it's really apparent the shadows suck
they don't extend out very far and we
don't get that nice shadowing on the
distant blocks
cascading shadow maps is typically the
answer to these kind of large landscapes
and as luck would have it there are
options in 3.js that i was able to
integrate
now we peek out from the corner of the
map here it looks great and we have
shadows going on
if you look in the distance you've got
shadows but you've also got shadows
nearby
and both of them have enough detail
i can also inject some of my own shader
code into 3.js for these cubes add some
tri planar mapping and noise that saves
me from actually modeling a level
and that gets me this kind of neat
futuristic look i like it
i also want to get some bloom in here
but 3.js doesn't quite do what i want so
i copy pasted theirs and i'm rewriting
it slightly to be driven by the alpha
channel
that way i can selectively bloom those
light emitting squares and even my shots
have a kind of glow to them but nothing
else does
i also played with the sky a bit what i
did was i combined a cube map of the sky
with a cube map of stars
then i drove the mix between those using
the sky's luminance and applied some
color grading
there's also a bit of rotation using
time and i added that for that small bit
of movement to keep it from being
totally static
i also bloom out the sun manually via
the shader so you get a sort of bleed
over effect in that direction
this also means that those force fields
on the droids they glow a bit now which
improves the look quite a bit i also
took the opportunity to add a little
radial blur effect it has a simple fall
off from the center with a bit of basic
color manipulation
and here it is an action
when activated i contrast the center and
desaturate a bit towards the sides
i don't know see what works for you
there's also a subtle vignette around
the edges of the screen because i like
the look
anyway that's about as far as i feel
like taking this it works i've got the
beginnings of something here maybe
somebody wants to actually take this and
turn it into a real game
so the code will be available on github
look for an announcement on twitter or
when it's available
until next time cheers